what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i was on the clock jack i know exactly
when that phone clicks
and you're using all three of them yeah
i'm using all three of them i was a bad
[ __ ]
oh yeah so when i saw all those cops i
was like
this ain't a game they're gonna [ __ ]
get me
so i went home to my girlfriend i told
her what i had seen
and we agreed on turning myself in there
was only a problem
i had a big [ __ ] problem on that
night miami vice don johnson was
marrying sheena eastman
you're you're a huge man i'm a huge
miami vice fan
i'm waiting for this [ __ ] wedding i'm
getting a grammar blow i'm getting
chinese food
i'm [ __ ] my girlfriend and i'm gonna
celebrate the wedding
my man crockett is gonna marry sheila
[ __ ] easton on national tv
i got a [ __ ] dilemma hit the level
you think you're [ __ ] this is real
retardation
i was like i got the cops looking for me
and i'm worried about a wedding
not
people know you know like when you guys
on patreon i'm
24 i don't know what to do let me tell
you what i was doing at 24.
i was going to imaginary cocaine
weddings
i'm the guy you want to listen to i've
done everything stupid in the world
i didn't even tell you what happened or
not after i ate that pill
i found the pill on the floor there's
one right here yeah no it wasn't a joke
this was a [ __ ] boogaloo pill and i
ate it had a rough night that night
i fell asleep on my wife twice like
talking to her
she's like where you going i got it she
goes you fell asleep talk to me anyway
i uh i know i'm in trouble but i got
this wedding
i'm gonna say like he's really gone why
didn't you be like the best man in your
head or something
i got this wedding together i'm gonna
watch elvis
alligators is he there so i said [ __ ]
this
i'll turn myself in by nine
i'll talk to him i'll talk about this
you mean nine a.m on saturday morning so
you can watch friday night because if i
remember correctly wasn't my everybody's
friday night
10 p.m was it nine nine ten yeah yeah i
go if i go in that nine and talk to them
i'll be home by eight
thirty the most boring person in the
world
right i sit in my room i smoke joints i
go to the gym
i go to a nice restaurant like whatever
is like something local
to get the local flavor and i'm back in
my hotel room yeah those days of
drugging and all that [ __ ] those days
are gone yeah
we smoke a joint after the show in front
of the hotel
and then every man goes their own way
you get a bag of doritos
and you take it to your room and watch
law and order too maybe maybe you spank
one out you do that
the highlight is that spank that you do
around three o'clock in the afternoon
where you don't you don't [ __ ] around
with tissues you get and not even a hand
towel you get the bath towel
and you drape that thing from your chest
down your balls and you get
lotion i i'm a dry guy i usually just uh
i don't use anything when i'm in a hotel
i get that lotion
i fi i fill my hand
with that [ __ ] that's disgusting that is
really
[ __ ] disgusting you can't be a normal
catholic and just going to
hotel shower before i'm leaving i get on
the floor i bang one out i come on my
own stomach
i loof it off it's good luffa chemicals
and sperm
i don't put it on my face just in case
it attracts different people
you know gay men could smell that sperm
on your cheek and they go [ __ ]
bananas it's like cologne
yeah yeah it's like shannon you put it
on your [ __ ] neck it's like high
karate
next thing you know [ __ ] you got gay
men you're in an lgbtq parade you're
playing the drums for the go goes
you know
we gotta have some fun greg for simmons
if we're going to go down we're going to
go down in flames you know what i'm
saying i don't give a [ __ ] no more
yeah he graduated in february 84. okay
thank you but
we'll get you a job because in fact you
got a job that's perfect for you italian
i don't know i'm cuban he goes don't say
that to him just tell him you're a
talent
i'll never forget this is horrible he
gives me this piece of paper and he goes
go down there they want to talk to 9 45.
now if you know anything about me i'm
going to get there at [ __ ] nine
that's how i was raised okay so i get
there at five after nine i get there
with my suit my girlfriend goes with me
we are down to the
the money we took on the bus to get that
that's what we have we don't have a
diamond money
every dollar we have we just spent on
the bus right there
she's waiting outside i go inside
only this could happen to me now i i
didn't i
i didn't have the rocking robin's job
yet like i was going for an interview
that night later
this was my first interview of the day
and this is for a lunchtime bartender
so i go in there and i'm like the paper
says i'm looking for
all right all right
all right hello i'm here at nine o'clock
9 45.
you know the coffee's on no art
i walk a little deeper all right all
right
i keep walking and there you go
there's an office wide open
no no with the bank deposit and then
it's wide open oh man with stacks of
money
i'm like oh my heart's about to get
ripped
three two
and i just start taking that stack of
cash
i'm putting the cash down my pockets
because i've done some bad
i'm putting it down my pockets i'm
putting it in my jackets
i take everything but i'm go i'm a
[ __ ] gavon
i go for the quarters the stacks are ten
dollar quarters
and i put them more on this pocket here
because this pocket was filled with cash
so when i walk out of the office i walk
in and my jacket is twisted
this side's all heavy it's all twisted
i walk out the guy's like hey what are
you doing here i'm like
i'm looking for steve he's a steve we
got no steve here i'm alright
i thought you were my 9 45 i go no no no
i'm not looking for a job my friend told
me to meet him here
he goes oh i'm sorry what restaurant i
go i think it's amelia's because
i think that's down the corner and i
walked out of there
and that's when i heard him go come back
and by that time i grabbed my girlfriend
we just took off
20s were flying out of my jacket we're
running up the [ __ ] hills of san
francisco
we finally see a bus and we get on the
[ __ ] bus and we jump on it
oh if we get to the back we're like was
that close she goes what the [ __ ] just
happened
let me tell you what just happened i
started giving like 100 000
quarters and i'm taking 20s out of every
[ __ ]
suitcase i got every every package
and also we counted up i don't know a
thousand bucks
we put in our pocket she had a hundred
quarters as i'm getting off the bus
a little old lady goes who's 20 dollar
bill is this
i know it's mine but [ __ ] it you take
him for good luck
she goes god bless you so [ __ ] and i
made this call
thank you how to cancel the cuba trip
they were waiting for you
yeah i know i know thanks for setting
that up but we'll get there
we'll get there my aunt was gonna get
you dick sucked
by the best dick sucker in cuba she's 58
and she's missing like 18 and they say
she rubs them with a little gummies
and she plays congas at the same time
they had
they had plans for you but i'm sorry
best blow job in cuba she's 58 59
it's like an hour deal you leave there
you file for divorce immediately
because she lets you know what a blow
job is she twists your dick around
she uses it like one of those wrist
things you know those wrist pumps she
had in the [ __ ] 70s
i'm getting my wrists wrong she twists
your dick around and she
tongue licks your balls at the same time
and sticks a finger up your ass
it's it's it's tremendous the best
[ __ ] in cuba you missed it i think i
read about it in trip advisor
yeah yes it's the best 10 stars she's
not that good looking but once she
starts sucking forget about it
she juggles your balls she she takes i
heard she pokes your balls with two
fingers like an eyeball
it's tremendous i have to try it myself
i keep forgetting she shaves her
eyebrows and licks you right in the eyes
the whole time
oh my god and she lets you shave an
eyebrow while you get your dicks like
block her eyebrows she likes pain you
know what i'm
so they go see the kitchen guy he's
looking for help
so the kitchen guy was a black dude
maybe six foot six
310 pounds retired [ __ ] marine
whatever he was he was retired from the
service
this guy did not mess around his name is
mr yarber
big brother big burly brother looked
like the coach at georgetown
remember the old coach at georgetown he
looks just like that
just like that dude i i loved it
i loved that [ __ ] he used to
coach patrick ewing
yeah i can't even believe i came from uh
john john thompson what the [ __ ] his
name
yes john thompson so he
mr yarber says to me i go in there
and i had my file my paperwork in my
hand
that the counselor gave me he goes give
this to the kitchen guy
so i gave it to him and he looks like he
goes jose diaz
he goes you go he goes you look like a
baker
because you look italian what
nationality are you
i'm cuban sir he goes cabano that's good
you people put good seasonings in the
food
he goes i want you to be my baker
because have you ever baked before i go
never
he goes well there's instructions there
your first job is cinnamon muffins
i can't believe that you're in prison or
kidnapping charges and you're about to
make
cinnamon muffins
[Music]
no you are one of a kind man there ain't
nobody like you
so there's a there's another kid
there's another kid who who got there
with me
who he also made a baker and this kid
and me became tight he was a white kid
he came from a good family and he went
out and got drunk one night
and killed two old people this kid
this kid was like who can i compare
him to like just think of somebody that
likes
to never yes
and just because like steve simone yeah
made a mistake made one mistake
he was a college kid i'll never forget
him
because he was so scared and i had to
like hold him and tell him you're gonna
be fine
nobody's gonna mess with you we're in
the kitchen now
you know and uh we both got sentenced
like the same
like you know around the same time we
both ended up in the kitchen
and he knew a little more than me about
bacon
that's all i know and i was a little
older than he was
he was a real college kid and
we were making the cinnamon one we had
to get the next morning at lake four
and we're like reading that stuff and
we're mixing
you know they have all this industrial
type [ __ ]
so i don't know how to make [ __ ]
muffins whatever
they said four to two inch thing
and you put it with a swirl so i'm like
those things look [ __ ]
like little [ __ ] muffins i'm not
giving out those
if i'm gonna bake i'm gonna bake right
to cinnamon muffins
so i made these big [ __ ] flying sauce
and things
and i started putting them in the oven
he's over here with the cinnabon [ __ ]
oh yeah i'm over there trying to be
cinnabon
and whatever he called before i added
extra like whatever flour
put an extra pinch in there sugar put an
extra sugar in there
[ __ ] baking soda i just put extra
everything
and next thing you know the [ __ ] me
and the guy at [ __ ]
were waiting for the first bats to come
out and one of the
one of the cooks was a black guy his
name was chickenhawk
his real name was
i love the nicknames
his real name was spencer antoine
i loved him i loved him since day one he
was a black dude that had a james brown
haircut
but his eye used to wander and he really
was crazy
he took a liking to me he's like what
the [ __ ] is burning
and i go i don't smell nothing's burning
he goes what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
boy
something's on fire over there sure
enough the oven
was
like setting the fire in the prison
kitchen dude you're too
i'm gonna taste them if there's some
black people hate
it's [ __ ] fire
i thought you were going to say burnt
food
blueberries black people hate fire
just from a natural they just lose their
mind when there's a fire black people
it's in their dna
i love i love you to death african
americans
but you light a fire under that
african-american
they'll run [ __ ] quick of the kkk for
chasing
these brothers these brothers
you